today kids in foster care even those who
suffer from behavioral and mental health
challenges are not very likely to be
placed in a group care setting of the
425 000 children in foster care only 55
000 are in group homes treatment
facilities and other congregate care
settings a big drop since the early
2000s what's behind this decline in the
middle of the 20th century
philanthropists responded to reports of
orphanages as uncaring greedy operations
with a focused effort to keep more kids
at home or with foster families federal
and state governments joined in this
effort but today it's clear this
movement has gone too far despite the
good intentions of philanthropists
struggling foster kids now have few
places to go
last summer alone more than 400 children
were sleeping in offices in texas
philanthropists should focus on building
more quality congregate care facilities
like utah youth villages teaching family
model an evidence-based program where
married couples help kids develop the
skills they need to live in a real home
programs like this are the standard for
the future of group care
do you think that there should be more
quality congregate care facilities for
foster kids let us know in our poll also
let us know what other topics you'd like
our scholars to cover in 60 seconds and
be sure to like and subscribe for more
research and videos from aei